raindrops on roses and whiskers on
kittens bright copper kettles and warm
woolen mittens brown paper packages tied
up with strings these are a few of my
I was over in the living room on the
edge of the couch when the droughts
began to take hold the only strange
thing is I wasn't on any drugs there's
well the few instances of sobriety I've
ever experienced and never again will I
return to that nasty realm because the
same thing like what I saw on the
television then the world of LSD clearly
has more sense and logic than that of
reality hello eyebrow peak father Fozzie
journalism I've covered everything from
building Las Vegas to where the buffalo
roam but today today I'm here to tell
you about a very particular trick it is
a trip that I wish you never to take
again a trip of sobriety I will not lie
but it came from a very particular place
a children film a children's film I hope
never to revisit a children's film that
brought out horrid images that I hope
never to experience I can there's only
one children so that could possibly
bring out this kind of horrible trip in
any man is simply known as we're back a
dice roll back back to the dawn of time
when earth was spoken and the lava
flowed clearly these writers and
directors that fit off are more x2z than
they could chew because there is no
story structure or visual logic that
could be obtained from any reasonable
solar human being at least let's pray to
God
the fact that these disturbing images is
marketed as a children's film is
ludicrous and unkind clearly no
challenge I ever had to go through such
a whore punishment so take the ticket
right there right so we start off with a
pack of Highland and great as they pick
on the runt of the group named something
adorable unsure it's the writing's on
the wall time to leave the neck this
animal annoys me
he must be cast aside for more deserving
character development
now we're seeing a dinosaur playing golf
I am thoroughly confused oh wow there
little fella
where'd you fall from what's your name
bird seems rather unfazed that there's a
nicer playing golf but I'm not this
needs to be explained I'm smart buster
I'm one smart dinosaur hmm this isn't
working
I feel like I'm stuck in a far side
cartoon with no caption please explain
the logistics of this awkward moment I
wasn't always knew no siree no I started
off stupid and violent clearly something
you on this film have in common
so the dinosaur voiced by John come and
tell us the story about how he got to
this questionable introduction as it
turns out he used to live among the
dinosaurs millions of years ago he was
savage as the creatures were until this
futuristic monstrosity came to knock
some sense into him yeah before your
very eyes
well oh god what is that your poison
partner looks like a cereal mascot
that's been shut up I love the marshal
Jay Leno doing in a mattress for us
wonderful because Jay Leno's normal
voice wasn't obnoxious enough for every
project you haven't eat stuff like this
before so the flowing pus ball gets in
some brain literally it's a futuristic
cereal that makes you smarter the more
you eat it this was invented by a person
named captain neweyes which I'm sure I
will need after viewing this painters
work I live in the far future where all
the species all the planets have had to
learn but get along racism is gone all
hatred is abolished and Fox News is now
a candy store by the way the voice of
captain neweyes is done by Walter
Cronkite a journalist far on the other
edge of the spectrum but we won't hold
that against him imagine the way you do
so the dinosaur who is ingeniously named
Rex is brought in to meet the others
sodomized heavy meal toys I was a real
animal we all have regrets the things
I've stepped on we be bow so we got a
dinosaur on a spaceship that's run by a
dead news anchor and an annoying piece
of alien trappings this is Sarah like
Ronald Calvin and Hobbes fantasies
spaceman spiff travels to an alien craft
board
a source gets smarter from eating sugary
cereal hey a five-year-old can think it
up it's good for cinematic production
yes I wish radio lying down a path
forward I wish I could people done so
the new IFR tells them that his goal is
to use the time machine to travel back
in time and grant all the wishes of
children in the world I would use it to
stop 911 unethical jackass I mean the
Kennedy assassination the bombing of
Pearl Harbor
really none of these are important
compared to entertaining whiny willow
bastard children well while you're
taking requests here's a kid named
Hitler he just wants to start his own
Third Reich and bring joy and happiness
to the world well it's a great team that
wish oh but no new I sees it best to
take animals out of their natural
environment and into an unknown world of
feeling violence I can't see this going
right at all
now there are two people down there you
should know about one person is there to
help you
her name is dr. Julius bleed she won't
be voiced by man woman chef Julia Child
let's go randomness continue now the
other person you should know about is my
brother professor screweyes
insane and the barely likes to Laughlin
birds are randomly flying around he's
kind of retarded that way find dr. bleeb
and stay well clear of my dark and
unhappy brother beyond that just try not
to step on anybody why you're already
raping the laws of space and time what's
a few squash this and bystanders gonna
matter so he drops them off in the
middle of Hudson River that was nice of
him where they just so happened to come
across a kid named Louie on a raft who
is off to join the circus they expect us
to buy a lot this movie don't pay well
what are you I was a runaway to the
circus
do you clown sank me are you guys going
anywhere
we're going to the Museum of Natural
History that's perfect kid your honor
we're fucking dinosaurs how about a
little announcement of this miracle huh
welcome to New York City
Oh Rex turns into a drowning sore as
Louie manages to pick him up with some
heavy machinery
welcome kids oh we know how to operate
those things Power Rangers movie Last
Action Hero and now this what the hell
are we teaching our kids can't they
teach them more important things like
I'll be shooting a protester oh you
wouldn't these things happen well thank
you for that pointless detour movie if
while the characters managed to get a
splinter in his foot but then Wiggles it
up please be sure to show that - hey you
the bat can you fly solo it takes a
flying the pterodactyl hoping you can
find someplace they can hide by the way
what's with all the obsessing eyes shots
do we really need to see the movie told
from everybody's cornea we didn't like
to see the whole entire movie told like
this
I don't think so although your ality
comes across a girl named Cecilia who
loses her head so he tries to return it
to her fishing cause a misunderstandings
at all well that ain't only all left
field my father's very business and my
mother's very social hello Lisa Simpson
Howard does dragged ain't that your
voice becoming another character it's my
parent what about your parents
they're off doing other things
so she explains how her parents are
never around and how even on
Thanksgiving they would leave her behind
with no babysitter instead they would
just send her a picture of where they
vacation - wow these people are whores
look you think that's bad just listen to
the sheer terror of what Louie has to
put up with from his family you should
add my mother slobbering kisses all over
me in public she should meet you
crucified died across a fire look Bates
would do such a horrible thing I'm
running a week sure you are I am what do
you say you throw this hat away and come
fly with me I was gonna call child
services but um yeah right away to the
circus sounds good so she tosses her
head into the wind as we cut to the
fucking head still falling all right
Louie I'm game where you going with this
child is looking at the same hat a child
is looking at the same hat a child is
looking at the same hat a child is
looking at the same hat a child is look
the fuck purpose movie we need purpose
the whereabouts of this head is not
exciting cinema you need to try harder
so returning to the story where the
vomited remains of the story Sicilian
Louie returned to the dinosaurs and
thank me guru
now with this Peabody chatter what are
you some kind of lead a beaut huh
why you I've matter of fact dying I
think so on is getting a bullet source
uh that joke is below me I have all guys
okay this is clearly not anything you're
presenting a good time this is freaky
unnatural and stupid look they're in a
parade why I thought they were trying to
hide there is no reason for this
this is madness anarchy track rule back
to back to the dawn of time God now
they're singing this race of monstrous
lizards was truly this flamboyant I'm
not shocked and then fouled not just
hide or estate no your repeat spider-man
you fucking fascist we got American I
cut a hole pull back the rock to the
dawn of time and sing this song with me
don't real dinosaurs real dinosaurs well
how does that work
one child says the realest only
everybody believes it a sheep to the
slaughter this is an entertainment this
is a sign so the local authorities are
called in to stop amicus as the
dinosaurs going run amok
yes truly captain neweyes has brought
joy and wonder into our world what's
next placing a saber-tooth Tiger into a
children's orphanage
I I truly have no idea what I'm watching
right now well it was Triceratops the
grocery store with you got hot dogs some
ways man reading paper rubbery flashing
lights assumer this is the lamp of our
time on crystal left this is not normal
this is not normal and in the middle of
a fucking reptile zoo someone's been
giving booze to these bastards so
through a series of what I can only
describe its mental castration the
reptiles escape as they plan to meet up
for the kids in Central Park where the
evil professor screweyes coincidentally
runs a circus
I apologize we appear go trapped off in
a completely different cartoon that was
heinous so the kids say they want to
join the circus because this guy
certainly looks like a person you can
trust
as karai's decides to write up a
contract I try to keep things simple I
did nothing
my god is the script the subway explains
everything so he makes them sign the
contract in blood
okay blood what is he a sadist as the
dinosaurs come in and try to save them
come on kids come to the museum with us
a museum up not troy's they're not going
anywhere they're under contract to me
for a very long time
always read the fine print before you
sign kid or any print that that would
help so screw I shows them that he likes
to scare people in this circus and that
the monstrous dinosaurs would be a great
addition what's that it's brain drain
it'll take you back it'll make your
monsters you know do you really have to
invent something to make you dumber
that's why we have television video
games and Martin Lawrence movies so he
gives the toys to the kids which I just
turned them into tiny little monkeys he
makes a deal with the prehistoric wizard
crazy
you all agree to take the brain drain
and I'll rip up this contract and set
the kids free I'll take it you know I'm
sorry but aren't you a fucking dinosaur
I mean he comes up and says I have a
contrary you just feel like I am fucking
teeth oh I'm salt how is this a bad plan
so as the kids wake up they're greeted
by a clown played by Marty short who
apparently is so funny that they forget
all about their reptile friends being a
fucking danger dinosaur friends glow add
rise has um probably doing honest people
linked it up
he's probably lobotomizing up even as we
speak all right just sit there and laugh
you inconsiderate aunties you people
voted for Hubert Humphrey and YouTube
Jesus
yeah I don't forget him and go about you
we're honest dogs so when they finally
get their morality back they sneak into
the show and try to save their friends
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the most
terrifying go on the planet Earth yes up
here this is backcountry
don't wait for me parasites
holy jesus mommy's got em out this is
David Lynch's Circus nobody should be
subjected to us so the dinosaurs break
loose and try to attack scratch the
little New Yorker pussy tells them that
wouldn't be right to eat the bastard
know it I know you can't understand me
but you got that no bad happens
gore you Yoda nobody talks like that
there's no bad happen you win
don't ruin everything cuz you mad or
scared of something it can't be all
about that oh what's life for I know I
act like I'm the original dog guy but
that's the dog here - don't listen talk
talk to Pete don't be just another
flower boil in the way the world you've
done nothing but sing and skateboard on
trust finish the best or be a credit to
your species please leave - put him down
please
you fucking whore so the moral the story
is the next time I join fearsome animals
about to attack you just hug the fucking
thing as clearly that's the most
sensible thing to do so captain neweyes
comes in to look over the horrific mess
that he made and give himself a pat on
the back for it I heard your wish on my
wish radio very good let no bad happen
Louie you all right Rex did I do
anything bad
actually I have a list right here uh
sing with no I'm or purpose failing to
live up to your fearsome prehistoric
right triangle you were great you agree
to Louie don't do that
why not some ninjas that's what it is
you know you're right oh yeah anybody
anybody here should be kidding me I
don't like the slutty girl she had sort
of a Lolita thing going
it seems unnatural so just before they
head out that clown that looks like a
serial killer decides to go and tell him
awesome I blink Christie over announces
that's all she wrote keep my last bunny
here's my my my horn my buster my fake
arm my buckle glasses I'm backstage
passes my hat a business or my rabbit
his back they might hang a few bird like
pogo stick my jaw review my training
tongue gag chicken my lucky will do try
and a giant grown up and through
I can play help by eliminating no no not
this is the circumcision of comedy stop
talk to you insert a large desert cactus
a table so after he finally shuts its
pipe all the heroes take off in their
ship when suddenly this happens brother
rather hey when I am alone when I have
no one to scare I get very frightened
myself that grows good donkey to move it
so the dinosaurs lived the rest of their
days in a museum where they shot kids by
coming alive oh how adorably precious
meanwhile the kids parents who we never
see suddenly appear then they just
appear no lines no explanations no scene
of them getting together they just blink
and they're in the story like metric
well one of the girl's parents stopped
being whores did the teamworks
threatened to you does she dream to call
Johnny Cochran why boy warrant we need
explanation dammit
oh I forgot about this insipid diarrhea
dudes not a tough guy remember my story
why what did he teach you there's no
meaning to a story those little bastards
are still making fun of Enzo nothing's
changed if the world never grow up
always be a mama's bird bullshit this is
a horrible lesson I mean nothing was
accomplished god damn it you think with
five dinosaurs set loose in Manhattan
something will be accomplished but no
this was a waste of my time and energy
it had no purpose big letdown get a
moment try piglet alligator movie
framing visuals horribly dull storylines
this movie is a hole yellows often said
by former drug users that it's actually
possible to get more high without drugs
than you can with this movie is
chock-full of that
grants at that times the animation is
nice but it's just deprived of anything
that makes the art of cinema animation
look decent
it's a Despres savage work a work that
tries to show whimsical magic up your
ass until it comes out your mouth as
tots it deals whistling Zippity fucking
dude so do yourself a favor get off the
ride and get a refund I'm around peak
and I'm just another freak in the Freak
you